for tens of thousands of people this is
the final act of the journey full of
drama and horror
thus lasted weeks or even months and
covered thousands upon thousands of
miles we've joined a people and drug
smuggling cartel on a northern Mexican
border with the United States it's the
first time they've let Outsiders in and
it's never been filmed onboard a
somewhat terrified traveler is preparing
to jump the border north they want us to
move quickly as the night closes in this
is a popular route with competing gangs
and they rent access to the border by
the hour in a red and white shirt is
Pedro a guide they're known as coyotes
while desert dogs who know the routes to
the United States but is it quite easy
getting over Pedro tells me it's not
easy there's surveillance cameras and
border patrols everywhere
[Music]
we're getting near the border now it's
what we've gone into a night shot is
getting very dark out here and they're
very very jumpy they keep checking
seeing people coming people have anyone
around it's not so much actually the
authorities but more other gangs you're
stopped fighting amongst themselves
the boy has paid $6,000 to cross he
hopes to change his family's fortunes
back home and they stumped up the cash
they move forward a quick wave and
they're gone the wall a dark line short
distance away
there's people around the wish of
whether he there are heat sensors on the
time there heat sensors on the offense
which is just there which why the wonder
is going in the air but the guys have
disappeared in others other people we
think coming so we've got to get out of
here they didn't want us to get right
next to the fence because that we'd be
seen quite quickly this now is Tonica
then we're off another customer in a
multi-million dollar business delivered
over a thousand miles south from the
border is the Mexican city of tappet una
it's at the center of the people
trafficking business but it's a business
that's changed it's morphed into a
multinational coalition of crime
syndicates this is where most new
arrivals to Mexico come people
trafficking to the United States has
gone global and nobody knows how to stop
one of the largest new traveling
communities come from India Pakistan and
Bangladesh there are five curry houses
on this street alone each are paying
between 30,000 and 50,000 dollars to the
smuggling syndicate
the new arrivals are greeted with an
affectionate hug
despite the VIP costs the journey
through five or six countries to this
point have been horrendous
not general Simran jet says he's
traumatized by his trip with the
smuggling syndicate his 50-day journey
from Delhi included passing through
Ethiopia Peru Brazil Ecuador Honduras
Nicaragua El Salvador Panama and
Guatemala where he was robbed by the
military and the police and in Panama
watched as injured travelers were
executed and women routinely raped
has lots of weapon like gun support they
can survive in the jungle we've heard
women are attracted quite a lot did that
happen games with a great yeah cargo
mafia rape his story is not unusual
eight agencies say they've heard it many
times before what wasn't so well
understood until now is the size and the
sophistication of the smuggling
operation
hammy another Indian heading for the
United States says the trafficking
syndicate have operators in every
country on the route however network of
guides to transport the human cargo and
can buy off corrupt officials across
continents there are some little agents
in India and they also have contact in
Delhi and they Delhi peoples have Punta
Cana like other countries and those are
the man who control everything there are
50 to 60
person under them they control them from
out of central Latin America I think so
that my agent is in Europe that he is
controlling in this all these things
that agent and his network control
everything even this River border
crossing between Guatemala and Mexico
this is where the Indian boys crossed it
may look serene but this is one of the
busiest illegal trafficking routes in
the world
day and night makeshift rafts cross the
border
it never stops they bring cargo loads of
everything alcohol food weapons and
drugs but also these days the most
precious and fought over cargo of all
humans Steele Ramsey sky news on the
Guatemala Mexico border